[Music]
that's the real answer I mean the most
down-to-earth thing about me is my
parents and my circumstance creating the
framework we are unable to hear the
cheering right ready I want you this
could be a rant in itself you may want
to you'll do you'll do what you're gonna
do you're in a zone here I'm ready I'm
tired of talking about people having the
ability to tune out the negative I'm
done telling you to not worry about
haters and trolls and negative opinions
I'm actually flipping the [ __ ] script
on you and I'm gonna yell at and I'm
gonna push at and I'm just gonna try to
inspire or communicate a perspective for
you to stop hearing the cheering the
reason so many struggle with negativity
is because they over value positive
reinforcement you're addicted to people
telling you you're pretty you're
addicted to people telling you you're
good at basketball you're addicted to
parents and teachers telling you you're
a good student
you're addicted to opinions
once you learn how to not overvalue
somebody who's commending or
complimenting you is the second you go
down the path of dealing with the
reverse can give you power
fail boss doing this on this real life
it's gonna film people I'm gonna film us
doing this I have an idea of using me up
front and then the clip and then title
yeah let's try that or split screen I
think and then maybe fade me out
actually we haven't done that that could
be a good idea we haven't done a lot of
these I haven't done on Instagram where
I feed in and then it goes to the clip
so maybe we go with the split screen
which we know is work and then I feed
like maybe we get it where I'll fade out
and it goes to that one do that
Instagram live what's up sorry I'm
making go sideways but I'm charging my
phone that wouldn't stand up so you got
to go sideways what we're doing now is
taking you behind the scenes of how we
make the clips for Instagram where we do
talking over
so hopefully well I'm saltiest [ __ ] [ __ ]
football so you had a fire clip
yesterday were you going off about
judgment and you said people if you have
here who the only person on the planet
yeah there's something there
do you want to play all that yeah dude
good job I remember it good job Jason
more of that Jason it's still [ __ ]
game um yes just when it catches like my
ear yeah it's like we're just in the
yeah and he that makes sense to me but
whether you whether d-roc state what the
rock said it's easy but it's not and
even if he is it's good it's good it's
good
muscle memory to like find it it's gonna
help you in everything your own [ __ ] my
[ __ ] and editing and then and then
whether whether there's a way to do it
right then and there right whether you
have your phone and your screen shoot
the time and you go but look at the
footage whether as soon as it's done you
do your best to try to remember whether
it's you're taking a [ __ ] four hours
later and you're like [ __ ] clip you
write it down or text it in the thread
understand the other day you know she
and here's the clip and then I'll come
right back and add on top of it I really
really really think that it is a much
more macro thing this comes down to
judgment if there was nobody else on
earth everybody would be happy
Amen I'm telling you this is a judgement
game as you can see there it's really
interesting to me like there's some
thought that sprung there which I
realize my god it is literally and I've
been on this for [ __ ] two years it is
literally the judgment of others that
leads to so much unhappiness and and I
really genuinely believe that being the
only person on earth would lead to so
much happiness for that person and and
you're talking to somebody who
desperately loves to socialize interact
with people but I just absolutely wish
you nothing besides health the only
thing I could wish you is just a deep
deep understanding that other people's
opinions ultimately don't matter because
they don't have all the context on you
how can you value somebody's opinion of
you when they don't have the full
picture how and more importantly how can
you judge someone when you don't have
the full picture
[Music]
decry look at this post I just posted
this might be one of the better things
I've wrote look at Syria look at that
scary my dad was smiling actually it's
good I'm gonna check actually in a in a
lot of ways I'd like to start on next
seven or eight hours I'd like you have a
two or three finalist for me maybe you
know Tyler you have such a good sense of
where my vibe is so something may
clearly stand out for you but if I can
get on the call and fine with that but
I'd like renderings based on my drawing
ASAP Jeff when you talk to them about
renderings you got to show my drawing
we've got to do a version of that on the
side of the building if dad says that's
a go call him or find him right now and
make sure that's a go and then and then
the cup for the mean one and that's got
to be you need to take some pictures and
send it over to them you know what I
mean Jeff
sometimes and other times no
[Music]
this is fact not opinion perfect
execution because you can waste an
enormous amount of money on digital the
amount of people here who dabbled and
spent 3000 bucks on Facebook ads and
nothing good has happened is high right
cuz the ROI of something is predicated
on your skill and so but I can promise
you this and I'm real quick what is your
business you have multiple locations one
business one human story right physical
store right we're great there is no shot
that radio and television can outperform
Facebook and Instagram if they're both
perfectly executed here's why what
Facebook and Instagram let you do is
have a photo with an Asian American
family and then target Asian Americans
with an African American family and
target African Americans with an Ohio
State family versus a mission the level
of creative matching who you're reaching
to create relevance to make them stop to
buy your [ __ ] is unparalleled on digital
as you know you're not run you're not
doing 34 different reads on radio you
got one [ __ ] script and it's supposed
to get to everybody but it's not
relevant not to mention every day that
goes by everybody in here is listening
to Spotify or Apple music in their car
not the radio so the trends are against
consumption and then you can't do
personalization but people understand
this I can tell you what to do but
that's like me telling you guys
basketball is a good idea I don't know
if you've seen the collective bargaining
agreement but even average players in
the NBA are now making hundreds of
millions of dollars so I think you
should become a basketball player that's
no different than me telling you you
should you Facebook into it you have to
be good at it but if you own your
business I don't understand how you
wouldn't take 20 hours to either read
articles on Google or watch videos on
YouTube to get good at it and don't run
home and hire their 24 year old niece
because she's young and she'll get it
this isn't about slipping into the DMS
to hook up this is [ __ ] business
[Applause]
I can't wait to tell this story so the
story when tea rocks looking at is right
before I started Wine Library TV in 2006
hi in December of 2005 decided that I
wanted more innovation do more new
things beyond the offense like I just
talked about and I was gonna launch
gourmet library calm because I was
frustrated with liquor laws that I
couldn't ship everywhere which still to
this day as you guys know wine texts
Illinois Texas so I did that and I knew
I was gonna build a monster and then
everybody like oh my god that was the
photo where I'd read the first sight
however then I got sidetracked and
decided to do a vlog or a wine show on
on YouTube this new thing that I saw
like a week later or actually I already
knew about YouTube and was consuming it
and and that's why and now all these
years later did 14 years later on the
back of texting which is kind of like
the new retail innovation that I see I'm
gonna launch yummy text why um my text
sign up gourmet foods olive oils
cheese's you know threads jams
chocolates teas coffees at heavily
discounted prices for the highest
quality it's going to become the thing
vlog super happy that we're finally kind
of getting back into a regular comments
on the blog you know a couple days back
for that daily beat which allows me far
more contextual and real-time so right
now I just have now Trevor simians out
for a year so the Jets are now on their
third quarterback will probably put us
out before the game against the Patriots
I happen to be in Boston so never fun to
be in territory that is enemy but you
know it's really funny I
this jet season is turning out to be
very much like my big thesis which is
there was so much optimism you know we
made some big free agent signings we had
Sam Donald there too and then between
mono and seven in thirties and a tough
schedule and here we are you know with
the NFL week - and it's not looking
great and so that's life in business
like that's why I love sports so much
like you can have everything organized
and plan and and be optimistic and then
injuries take over and so yeah let's go
what's up man thank you brother that was
awesome
thank you very much
real pleasure nice to me hope you
enjoyed it thank you get home safe take
care
yeah okay I'll do some some podcasts
where you're about to see is probably my
most relevant up-to-date point of view
on the small business entrepreneur state
of the union marketing especially if
you're not rolling with a huge marketing
budget this is for all the people that
have less than $5,000 to spend on
marketing this year please pay attention
this is specifically to the jewelry
industry but it resonates with all SMBs
hi I guess peeps I hope you enjoyed this
episode
I really really appreciate all your love
any sharing of the podcasts or reviews
Spotify Apple wherever you're listening
to this whether it's one star five star
you're honest point of view of the
podcast would mean a lot to me at least
you can do it so we can't paint about a
go we go see that to break down scores
break news tell me what you're gonna do